[Music]
tell you what the wait is over to put
this man so that I have been waiting for
this moment but isn't weird that I'm
feeling nervous right now just to relive
it
again just to watch the real brother
breathe breathe right there breathe
breathe okay this week we are sending
camera to the farthest reaches of the
planet to pit him again some of the
truly great challenges that the world
has to offer I'm like sweating right now
I could send it today's battle
Ken can become a ninja warrior let's see
how he come on
hi I'm a Tempest Freerunning Academy
getting ready for the big day and by the
way I am training with American ninja
extraordinaire Jessie Graff we'll see
surely a couple things hopefully not
that my training started where every
course begins the floating steps ready
give it a shot I feel good I feel
coughing I'm okay
whoa after a few more tries I think I
got it down whoa good you're up yeah
well I'm full of muscle okay
next jesse tested my upper-body strength
my agility and my balance not pretty not
pretty
perspective
[Music]
ninjas trained in all different ways
from rock climbing trampolines pretty
much anywhere but a traditional gym and
Jesse
she does it with her pet pig samo hog in
the living room
she's renovated to a full ninja gym and
after only one more two hour training
session it was time to try the real
ninja course we are in Cleveland now I'm
telling you right now is getting real
and my ninja on the ground the one
that's going to help me through this a
one and only ninja Natalie Natalie Duran
showing she is among the best so I'm
going to be with you on the sidelines
even though everyone's yelling at you I
want you to listen to me because I'm
going to help you out with the cues that
should you do sometimes you slow down
speed it up breathe you know you forget
that a lot of times but that isn't going
to be hunt before I knew what the stage
was set the Sun was down and I was up it
was my moment of truth
first off tonight the man from
Entertainment Tonight it's going to be
the first one to tackle this horse
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Kamran jeppesen
here he goes tackling the course about
six - pounding here now on to the
rolling log or mat we know that Cameron
has nice hair but this is going to get
crazier like this is beyond the roll
come on Cameron looking relatively clean
shaven often goes with the stubble says
it makes him look more manly but Cameron
Mathison trying to keep that hair dry
Akbar and that was the manner payment
tonight
I think Cameron Mathison got a glimpse
of his don't handsome reflection in the
water it distracted him you can see him
clearly looking down going oh a hard
impact but all in all a great effort out
of Cameron Mathis it really was Matt so
I worked out an obstacle number three so
Kemp's Tata cam was a good feeling a
kind of can all right I'll take their
job we'll take that it wasn't kind of
can because I know I could have gone a
little bit further did that being hurt
when you fell and hurt a little bit they
invited me to try it next year again as
an actual ninja and I'm going to take
him up on it the new season of American
Ninja Warrior kicks off June 12th on NBC
you